FOR AND SALAS HOLDEN KALRA
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
YEAH I THINK IF WE DO HAVE ONE
ITEM ON CONSENT THAT IS H.
R. SEVENTY SEVEN AND THE MOTION
IS THAT THE I TO BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED AND MOVED TO THE FLOOR
LET'S WITH SOMEBODY LIKE TO
REMOVE THE ITEM FROM CONSENT
I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE HI GALLAGHER CHILD BY
TWO HI GONZALEZ HOLDEN --
KALRA I KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE MARK GRACE I
RIGHT THAT I HAVE IS OUT SO
THAT COMPLETES OUR BUSINESS
FOR TODAY I MISTAKENLY THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS FOR A
BIT SO THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU
CONSENT AGENDA CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE
GALLAGHER GONZALEZ SAID
KILEY THERE DOES JUST THEY
WERE VOTING ON THE CONSENT
OF JOB I AND I'M HERE RIGHT
GALLAGHER GONZALEZ
I THANK YOU HI
WE HAVE SOME OVER GALLAGHER
-- I THINK YEAH RIGHT THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR
THE DAY AND WE ARE A JUROR GEN